le 12 14 infos Sud Radio le face-à-face
des éditorialistes
ce vendredi avec un Robert Rochefort
vous êtes député européen et
vice-président du modèle et Adrien Gomis
militant social ensemble nous allons
commencer l'actualité et Cyril on va
commencer évidemment avec ce voyage très
controversé de parlementaire français en
Syrie
Hollande dénoncer la rencontre avec un
dictateur Manuel Valls à parler d'un
boucher Nicolas Sarkozy est qualifié ses
élus de gugusse François Bayrou dénonce
un bricolage irresponsable cette visite
vous a-t-elle choquée Robert Rochefort
disons qu'en tout cas elle me met très
mal à l'aise il est clair que il y a
aujourd'hui chez Monsieur Assad le désir
de se réhabiliter de se refaire une
sorte de capital de sympathie supposée
avec les Occidentaux et je trouve que ce
n'est pas à des parlementaires français
a contribué à cela d'autant plus qu'il
me semble que vu l'aggravation de la
situation là-bas je crois que je ne
rentre pas moi en tout cas dans la
démarche du moindre mal qui monsieur
Assad contre daesh je crois
malheureusement que il faut les
combattre même si aujourd'hui c'est
daesh qui est incontestablement l'ennemi
le plus
importants de faire cette démarche
pourquoi l'ont-ils fait à votre avis je
pense que quand on est parlementaire
vous savez on est sollicité par tout un
tas de diplomatie plus ou moins
affichées ou indirect de ces pays et on
essaye de vous dire venez voir il faut
que vous puissiez comprendre sur le
terrain je pense que dans 90% des cas
les parlementaires résistent et puis de
temps en temps il y en a qui
acceptent d'aller voir là-bas peut-être
certains le font-ils sans arrière-pensée
je n'en sais rien mais il est clair que
ensuite ils sont utilisés manipulés et
que évidemment ça ne peut pas rester une
affaire privée comme Monsieur Bapt a
essayé de de le dire hier Adrien Gomi
pour vous ils sont irresponsables c'est
par le moteur ou justement ça fait
partie de leur mission d'aller voir sur
place ce qui se passe non non je je
partage en grande partie ce que vient de
dire Robert Rochefort il est certain que
lorsque l'on décide de se rendre en
Syrie pour rencontrer un dictateur qui a
quand même près de 200 000 morts sur sur
la conscience c'est un acte
irresponsable d'autant plus que
l'argumentaire qui consiste à dire que
c'est une visite strictement privée on
connaît Benjamin lassade on connaît ces
méthodes de communication il y a un
risque très fort et on le savait
d'instrumentalisation et donc avec un
avis négatif du cadorsay il ne fallait
pas que les quatre parlementaires il
aille pour autant pour autant
j'apporterai un bémol sur deux points
premièrement sur le caractère ridicule
des propos de Nicolas Sarkozy qui avait
oui qui avait reçu en grande pompe
Bachar al-Assad en 2000 à Paris le 14
juillet place de la Concorde avec les
petits fours etc en plus il était
particulièrement proche de lui François
Fillon avait été le premier chef d'État
à se rendre depuis 1977 le gouvernement
de chef de gouvernement depuis 1977 à se
rendre en Syrie en 2010 donc voilà on
sent une sorte d'hypocrisie sur la
question et d'autre part et c'est là où
je suis peut-être en accord avec Mia
lorsqu'il dit que Bachar el-Assad reste
quand même un
interlocuteurs
il reste quand même on peut pas rester
dans une position c'est du moins mon
point de vue personnel du Nini entre
daesh et Assad on peut condamner ce que
ce que fait Bachar el-Assad pour autant
ne doit pas forcément rompre
systématiquement et à vitam æternam les
relations avec lui oui je voudrais
rajouter quelque chose n'oublions pas
dans toute cette affaire on parle tout
le temps de daesh là on parle de la
Syrie il faut parler de l'Iran aussi
parce que l'Iran est derrière tout ce
qui se passe là-bas et l'Iran et d'abord
à mon avis on le dit pas assez souvent à
l'origine de de l'islamisme de la partie
insupportable qui se réclame pas de
l'islamisme et qui est très très loin
des fondamentaux de l'islam et ça ça
date de la révolution de la soi-disant
révolution romaniste et aujourd'hui avec
la question de l'accession de ce pays à
l'arme nucléaire donc on est vraiment
dans une situation où il ne faut pas se
tromper et même si on sait très bien que
tout ce qui correspond aux guerres et
aux rivalités entre les factions chiites
et les factions sunnites il faut pas
rentrer dans des logiques de de prise de
partie des un vis-à-vis des autres il y
a quelque chose où il y a un danger
majeur je crois qu'effectivement il y a
une forme de guerre je crois que nous
sommes dans une forme de guerre je crois
qu'effectivement quand on est dans une
forme de guerre il peut arriver à un
moment donné qu'on est un ennemi
principal mais l'ennemi principal ne
veut pas dire que l'ennemi qui serait
pas principal un moment donné doit
devenir un allié c'est toute la nuit
Rochefort est exact pour autant j'ai
peut-être une interprétation différente
du rôle de l'Iran qui
on l'a vu avec assez récemment avec les
États-Unis devient non pas un allié mais
du moins un partenaire dans la lutte
contre daesh il faut pas oublier la
cette rivalité importante entre les
cheats et les sunnites et quel que soit
les réserves et tout à fait justifiées
qu'on peut avoir à l'égard de du
fonctionnement
anti-démocratique du régime iranien sur
l'ensemble de la géopolitique du
Moyen-Orient il faudra également lancer
des passerelles avec le gouvernement
iranien et engager un débat qui dit
engager un débat ne veut pas dire
cautionner ce qui est fait notamment sur
la politique interne mais il faudra
tendre la main également à l'Iran sur le
plan international ce qui a déjà
entrepris alors là permettez-moi de vous
dire que là je suis en désaccord radical
les atrocités les lapidations tout ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui en Iran sous
couvert de ce régime nous ne pouvons pas
comment dire pactiser avec ce régime je
suis favorable à une position beaucoup
plus ferme et je effectivement que la
diplomatie américaine soit dans une
sorte de début d'amorce d'une réelle
politique si effectivement ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui avec daesh devait se
traduire par une tolérance plus grande à
l'égard de l'Iran nous aurions abandonné
la peste pour le choléra je crois que il
faut être extrêmement extrêmement
vigilant sur ce point mais voilà qu'il y
a de rien Gomis je voudrais revenir avec
vous sur ce voyage donc des
parlementaires est-ce que ça est-ce que
ça valait une convocation aux parties
socialiste comme ça sera le cas pour
Gérard batte mardi
écoutez il y a des instances au Parti
socialiste qui vont être chargés de de
dire et de donner leur avis sur sur ce
déplacement du rabat je pense que ça
n'intéresse pas vraiment les Français de
savoir si Monsieur Babs sera sanctionné
ou non par le Bureau national et son
premier secrétaire le premier secrétaire
du Parti socialiste Jean-Christophe
Cambadélis
ce qui est regrettable c'est que comme
je disais tout à l'heure ces quatre
parlementaires ils sont allés sans
l'avis du cadorcet de fait il est vrai
que je rabatte devra en répondre
notamment à son groupe politique à
l'Assemblée nationale ça me paraît
évident alors moi oui
je voudrais dire bon le Parti socialiste
d'une certaine façon on pourrait en rire
si derrière cela il n'y avait pas des
questions qui sont des questions
évidemment très graves mais vous voyez
bien que cette affaire de convoquer
monsieur Bapt arrive quelques jours
après l'idée de savoir si on va punir ou
pas ceux qui n'ont pas soutenu
à l'Assemblée nationale il y a une sorte
de comment dire de de
caporalisme que le Parti socialiste
essaye de mettre en place pour laisser
croire qu'il est imparti unique et
évidemment ceci se fait quelques
semaines avant les élections
départementales alors qu'en réalité ce
parti est aujourd'hui dans un désordre
et dans une absence de cohérence
absolument fantastique et incroyable il
y a des gens qui vont qui vont dans tous
les sens qui tirent dans tous les sens
et effectivement là il y a cette idée
alors qu'on sait très bien d'ailleurs
qu'en plus les sanctions dans ce genre
d'affaires ça ne ça ne mène pas comment
dire à grand chose c'est beaucoup plus
quelque chose qui est fait pour faire un
affichage que pour recréer de la
cohésion moi je crois que ça ne
réglera pas les conflits intérieurs du
Parti socialiste un réduira pas les
écarts mais ça fait partie aujourd'hui
d'un théâtre offre ce parti qui est
pourtant un grand parti dans l'histoire
de notre pays mais qui va très mal
alors restons dans cette région puisque
nous allons parler maintenant sur Sud
Radio de ces destructions de l'État
islamique qui a massacré des trésors
antis au musée de mossoulan en Irak on
voit les images sur les chaînes
d'information depuis ce matin images de
propagande évidemment filmée et diffusé
par l'État islamique qui s'en prend à
l'art après sans être pris aux hommes
Robert c'est la même chose vous savez
les hommes les hommes n'existent que
parce qu'ils sont des êtres qui ont été
façonnés par des sociétés qui ont bâti
des cultures quand on veut anéantir des
cultures ça veut dire que l'on on
anéantit des hommes donc c'est
exactement la même chose même si vous
m'empêche pas de croire que évidemment
quand on a comme c'est le cas
actuellement ces chrétiens d'Orient que
l'on
maltraite que l'on déporte que l'on
otage enfin que l'on massacre enfin
évidemment je je me sens encore plus
concerné par cette question alors ce
matin il se trouve que cette sur les
destructions
antique que l'émotion se fait mais c'est
fondamentalement la même chose c'est
c'est l'expression d'un groupe qui veut
tuer une société qui existait à avant ce
qu'il prétend être qui est une société
qui veut présenter un modèle totalitaire
et voilà il ne faut pas se tromper c'est
la même c'est la même force qui
s'attaque à ce que font des hommes
lorsqu'il construisent quelque chose et
je dois dire qu'en plus comment dire
nous nous venons enfin peut-être moins
nous les occidentaux mais nous venons de
la construction de ce passé se passer
est important pour nous construire un
avenir donc il y a quelque chose qui est
qui est monstrueux au sens cette fois-ci
symbolique évidemment du terme c'est une
provocation ou pas seulement
moi je crois pas que c'est une
provocation je crois que c'est je crois
que c'est un acte de
d'autodafé du passé de même que à
certaines époques ont fait des autodafés
on brûlant les livres du moment là c'est
un auto un autodafé culturel extrêmement
fort non c'est un projet extrêmement
cohérent alors même si vous savez il y a
des choses beaucoup moins claires qui se
passent aussi parce que certaines de ces
œuvres de son pas
détruites mais sont en fait ensuite
revendus au marché noir pour récupérer
de l'argent pour cette cause donc tout
ça il y a parfois aussi dans ces dans
ces moments là il y a aussi de la réelle
politique qui est derrière cette
présentation au monde mais non non c'est
c'est pas c'est c'est de la provocation
évidemment mais c'est de la provocation
révélatrice d'un vrai projet de
destruction de société Adrien Gomy votre
réaction vous sur cette destruction 3000
ans d'histoire quand même oui bien sûr
et je voudrais insister sur la sur deux
points importants qui me semblent assez
important le premier c'est qu'il y a une
mise en scène la communicationnel il ne
faut pas négliger les djihadistes de
l'État islamique sont
véritablement très forts dans la
communication de l'horreur à chaque fois
si on remarque qu'il y a un pas de plus
qui est qui est assuré par les
djihadistes dans l'horreur les vidéos de
décapitation ensuite la vidéo du pilote
brûlé vive dans une cage maintenant une
vidéo avec comme vous le disiez tout à
l'heure des œuvres particulièrement
importantes dans l'histoire irakienne
qui sont détruites il y a une volonté de
choquer
c'est clair il y a une volonté de
choquer en Occident et partout dans le
monde d'ailleurs et le problème c'est
que c'est au-delà de la tragédie
culturelle que ça peut représenter je
lisais assez récemment le le communiqué
de presse du Conseil de sécurité des
Nations Unies sur la protection du
patrimoine irakien c'est vrai que c'est
particulièrement inquiétant pour aussi
principalement les habitants qui vivent
là-bas qui n'ont plus aucun droit
ni de fumer ni d'écouter de la musique
dans la rue pour les femmes qui n'ont
plus le droit de sortir sans je cite
référent masculin c'est vraiment une
situation très inquiétante et lorsqu'on
s'attaque à l'art lorsqu'on s'attaque au
patrimoine on s'attaque à l'humanité
alors l'UNESCO demande une réunion
d'urgence du Conseil de sécurité de
l'ONU que peut faire l'ONU justement
contre
il faudra voir l'ONU de toute manière
rendra son avis sur la sur la question
c'est un c'est un problème assez épineux
très très épineux on avait connu ça avec
vous souvenez sûrement la démolition des
des Bouddhas de baignade en 2001 par
l'État Liban en Afghanistan lorsque
c'est fou s'attaque au patrimoine c'est
très difficile d'avoir une réponse
immédiate j'espère que des sanctions au
niveau international seront prises
j'espère que les États et la France en
particulier se poseront
contre ces exactions et c'est
destruction de l'oeuvres d'art sur la
réponse véritablement à apporter par le
Conseil de sécurité des Nations unies on
en sort un peu plus dans les prochaines
dans les prochains jours mais ce qui
restera pas un peu symbolique cet avis
bien entendu enfin il est clair que les
il est clair que les Nations Unies
feront une une déclaration
supplémentaire quand je dis ça ne croyez
pas que je sois cynique et que je pense
que unine servent à rien je ne pense pas
du tout mais il est évident que il est
évident qu'on est qu'on est loin de ce
qu'il faudrait faire alors si vous me
posez du coup me poser la question du
goût qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait faire je
pense que c'est évidemment l'ensemble du
sujet c'est à dire c'est le combat
contre l'État islamique et vous me
permettrez en tant que député européen
et en plus du sud-ouest de préciser que
j'aimerais que l'Europe soit plus unie
soit plus mobilisé et soit plus active
pour montrer comment dire une image
claire et une participation à l'action
de la Coalition pour se battre contre
contre l'État islamique contre daech
contre voilà c'est c'est la seule
réponse c'est la seule réponse avec une
perspective d'efficacité et c'est une
réponse évidemment largement militaire
et pas simplement diplomatique mais elle
doit être évidemment suivi elle doit
être précédée par tout ce que la
diplomatie mondiale peut faire quand
elle peut faire quelque chose parlons
maintenant des élections départementales
Manuel Valls a tenu un premier meeting
de campagne hier soir à Carcassonne il a
appelé les électeurs de gauche à battre
le Front national pour faire vivre je le
cite les valeurs de la République et la
raison de s'en prendre au Front national
ce sera le premier adversaire du PS aux
élections Auber Rochefort écoutez
d'abord il est chef normalement d'une
majorité dans la 5e République le Chef
le Premier ministre c'est celui qui va
effectivement au combat quand il y a un
combat politique donc je trouve que il
est étonnant qu'on soit étonné qu'il
s'en mêle mais ça veut aussi dire qu'il
a hésité à avant de s'en mêler vous
savez très bien que ça donnait lieu à
des tractations au sein du Parti
socialiste et puis que on a décidé un
peu dans la dans la panique il y a
quelques jours d'envoyer les ministres
et le premier d'entre eux au charbon
alors que c'est un débat puisque vous
savez que par exemple aux dernières
élections il y a beaucoup de municipales
il y a beaucoup de candidats sur le
terrain qui voulaient pas voir de
ministre tellement c'était plutôt
quelque chose qui était repoussoir que
quelque chose qui favorisait
une dizaine de meetings parce que parce
que parce que tout le monde sait bien
que finalement les départementales c'est
à la fois des élections locales mais des
élections politiques je l'ai d'ailleurs
dire que la réforme qui fait alors bon
courage pour tous les électeurs du
Sud-Ouest et d'ailleurs ceux qui
maintenant doivent voir 4 noms là où
avant ils élisaient un conseiller
général une femme non non c'est 4 parce
qu'il y a le binôme de titulaire plus le
binôme donc en fait c'est quatre noms
donc vous voyez bien qu'on éloigne
encore plus les citoyens de de ce qu'ils
vont élire aucune raison justement ça
paraissait parce que je vais vous
répondre parce que en France quand on
veut faire quelque chose qui entrait
normalement à la simplification ou la
réforme politique si on n'a pas une idée
extrêmement claire dans la tête on fait
du complexe on fait du complet qui
regardez tout ce qui s'est passé tout ce
qu'on attend comme simplification dans
les collectivités territoriales on a
rajouté des étages supplémentaires on a
fait un mille-feuille quand on n'a pas
une idée claire or le gouvernement
n'avait pas une idée claire puisque vous
avez bien vu que l'idée de fusionner les
départements et les régions c'est
quelque chose qui n'est pas allait
jusque là donc tant qu'on n'a pas une
idée claire et bien on fait des choses
compliquées on utilisant quelque chose
au cas particulier que je trouve un
mauvais prétexte qui est une parité
obligée en ayant un homme et une femme
mais vous me permettrez quand même de
dire que ce qui est nouveau qu'est-ce
qui est nouveau ce qui est nouveau c'est
que il y a un mois on était dans l'idée
de l'unité nationale après le drame de
Charlie Hebdo et puis de l'épicerie
cacher de Vincennes et puis les choses
sont passées par là le président de la
République a cru pertinent de faire une
conférence de presse dans laquelle il
n'a pas du tout abordé les questions
économiques et sociales et malgré la
petite embellie très très contestable
d'ailleurs dans les chiffres du chômage
il y a deux jours les Français tous les
sondages toutes les études le montrent
se rappellent au fait que il y a une
réalité économique et sociale qui est
notre pays ne pas bien et donc les
élections deviennent redeviennent ce
qu'elles sont évidemment politiques et
évidemment le Parti socialiste craint
une Bérézina au niveau de ces élections
départementales alors que Manuel Valls
qui est quelqu'un de courageux on sait
bien c'est un leader courageux que
Manuel Valls prennent la capote sur lui
et puis ils se mettent à traverser
malgré les intempéries les territoires
français pour aller faire des meetings
bon c'est son rôle on verra bien et je
crois qu'en tout cas c'est logique
Adrien Gomi est-ce qu'il mélange les
genres Manuel Valls comme le dit
d'ailleurs Florian Philippot au Front
national en désignant l'adversaire
l'extrême droite comme l'adversaire dit
Florian Philippot non seulement de la
gauche mais du pays non pas du tout il
ne mélange pas les gens et je pense que
il fait partie des rares socialistes à
se positionner sur la question face à
cette montée très inquiétante de
l'extrême droite avec un discours
offensif républicain sur les valeurs qui
sont les nôtres sur la laïcité qui
priorité pendant trop longtemps
délaissés à gauche notamment au niveau
local avec souvent des des une forme de
faiblesse à l'égard des communautarisme
qui ont pu se mettre en place donc ça
j'approuve vraiment
ce discours à la fois offensif
républicain et contre l'extrême droite
qui prévoit de faire quand même un sacré
score au départementale avec des
candidats je vais reformuler ma question
les électeurs ce qu'ils attendent c'est
pas qu'on leur dise vous allez très mal
voter ça va être stupide si vous votez
Front national ils attendent exactement
ce que vient de dire Robert Rochefort
qu'on se qu'on leur donne des des
solutions et des projets pour sortir le
pays de la situation dans laquelle il
est bien sûr mais c'est ce que le
gouvernement s'emploie à faire avec
difficulté certes mais c'est ce qui
semble à faire il faut aussi je suis pas
forcément en accord avec vous il faut
aussi rappeler ce qu'est l'extrême
droite il y en a marre de ce discours à
chaque fois j'ai l'impression qu'on
prend les électeurs pour des débiles
quand on fait ça pas du tout il s'agit
juste de rappeler un certain nombre
d'éléments que les que les électeurs
n'ont pas n'ont pas forcément
en mémoire par exemple les déclarations
sur les Twitter sur les Facebook de
certains candidats du Front national on
nous parle de banalisation du Front
national lorsque certains appellent
clairement homertre de de musulmans
alors qu'ils sont candidats investis par
le Front national à des élections et
quand parallèle monsieur Philippot vient
nous dire qu'il faut des diaboliser le
Front national mais le Front national se
diaboliste tout seul il faut le rappeler
moi je crois qu'il faut pas je crois
qu'il faut pas qu'on tombe dans le piège
de faire d'une mobilisation qui pourrait
paraître légitime contre le Front
national l'alpha et l'oméga du jeu
politique d'aujourd'hui parce que c'est
justement le piège j'allais dire
proposer vous savez souvent le Front
national dit
UMPS en disant droite et gauche uni et
défendre le système contre moi je dis
qu'il y a un autre piège qui est les
parties aujourd'hui participent parce
qu'il est au pouvoir et le Front
national comment ensemble évidemment pas
du tout sur les valeurs me faites pas
dire ce que je ne dis pas mais dans une
sorte de jeu politique ou quelque part
voilà on
parlerait de ça comme si c'était la
question fondamentale de la société
française moi je ne crois pas et je vais
même vous dire quelque chose puisque je
suis centriste et que je suis partisan
de la proportionnelle le plus possible
dans toutes les élections ce qui est
d'ailleurs le cas aux élections
européennes et bien ça ne me fait pas
peur que le Front national soit un parti
qui présente ses candidats et qui
éventuellement et ses élus je vous
signale par exemple au Parlement
européen pour les Français nous sommes
74 députés français il y a 24 députés du
Front national il y en a un sur trois
des députés français au Parlement
européen qui sont du Front National et
bien écoutez ça ne me fait pas peur
d'ailleurs j'en profite pour dire que
Monsieur Philippot qui est membre de ma
commission dont je suis vice-président
il ne brille pas comment dire par sa
présence parce qu'il n'est jamais là ni
par ses interventions donc je préfère
comment dire qu'il soit dans le jeu
politique et nous devons les combattre
mais rassurez-vous à chaque fois qu'il y
aura un second tour dans lequel il y
aura d'un côté des cand la républicain
qu'il soit centriste de droite ou de
gauche et en face un candidat du Front
national je n'aurais évidemment aucune
difficulté pour dire que c'est le
candidat du Front national qu'il faut
éliminer au second tour de Nini donc
Adrien
Rochefort a raison lorsqu'il dit que le
Front national ne doit pas être l'alpha
et l'oméga de la politique française
pour autant on ne doit pas forcément
avoir de complaisance à l'égard des des
candidats à l'égard du staff du Front
national
sous couvert d'un respect qui doit être
le même à l'égard de l'ensemble des
formations politiques quelque chose m'a
vraiment interpellé j'en parle assez
souvent avec des collègues au Sénat vous
prenez l'exemple des dernières
législatives très intéressant vous avez
déjà l'angle qui bien sûr se présente
dans les Vosges comme tout le monde le
sait n'est pas vraiment un élu des
Vosges peut-être de la place des Vosges
pas des Vosges et on lui tombe dessus à
juste titre en disant parachutage etc
etc Marion Maréchal-Le Pen attend les
résultats de la présidentielle voient
que l'une des CIR description ou sa
tente oui puisque c'est une affaire de
famille fait le plus gros score
et est situé dans le sud de la France
elle décide de se parachuter dans le sud
de la France alors qu'elle n'y a jamais
mis les pieds qu'elle est qu'elle n'a
même pas terminé ses études de droit à
ça et est élu avec un parachutage assez
hallucinant aucun média n'en a parlé
aucun média n'en a parlé aucun homme
politique n'a osé s'aventurer sur cette
c'est pas la première élaboration
il y a des parachutés de bien sûr je
vous assure qu'il y en a vérité
peut-être qu'un jour peut-être qu'un
jour mon cher mon cher Adrien vous serez
vous-même du parachuté et qu'à cet égard
vous serez comment dire un peu un peu
moins comment dire dans la foule de la
jeunesse par rapport au fait de dénoncer
ça oui bon je trouve pas que le le le
soit disant parachutage qui n'a pas eu
lieu de de Monsieur Jack dans les Vosges
et il faut et c'est vrai qu'il y a eu
beaucoup de
ça correspond à ce que je disais tout à
l'heure c'est-à-dire que c'est
aujourd'hui comment dire le pour le
Parti socialiste une une sorte de de
comment dire de de trucs de magicien
pour essayer de revenir comme à dire
dans le débat on essayant de ne pas se
trouver confronté à la réalité qu'on le
veuille ou non qui est que d'une part le
le Parti socialiste et est aux affaires
donc depuis maintenant 3 ans avec le
chômage qui progresse partout et que par
ailleurs les socialistes sont dans la
gestion des collectivités territoriales
depuis extrêmement longtemps et qui sont
effectivement devant un bilan qui n'est
pas forcément le bon et c'est pour ça
qu'il y aura le résultat des prochaines
élections on le sait déjà c'est dans
dans nombreux nombreux départements se
seront des départements qui seront
conquis par des alliances entre l'UMP et
des partenaires centrices avec l'UDI et
très souvent le modem il ne faut pas
juste il ne faut pas forcément
généraliser cette focalisation sur le
front national je prends le cas par
exemple de mon département je suis
originaire de Seine-et-Marne ou
l'ensemble des candidats dans les
différents cantons de Seine-et-Marne
présente avant tout le bilan de l'action
départementale et de la majorité qui a
été menée et ne se focalise pas
spécifiquement et spécialement sur le
front national donc peut-être que dans
certains cantons comme vous le disiez
tout à l'heure je ne connais pas
forcément tout les grands de France et
toutes les stratégies du PS d'ailleurs
mais il est sûr que ça doit
s'accompagner d'un certain nombre de
mesures assez fortes et je pense que
Manuel Valls as-tu rempli rempli
vraiment bien le rôle je te parle
maintenant du déplacement de François
Hollande aux Philippines à Manille il
s'y trouve encore aujourd'hui dans le
cadre de la préparation de la conférence
sur le climat à Paris à la fin de
l'année le chef de l'État espère un
accord ambitieux équitable et universel
sur le climat pour ce voyage il est
accompagné par deux actrices Marion
Cotillard et Mélanie Laurent quel regard
portez-vous justement sur sur ce voyage
est-ce qu'il faut mobiliser des des
stars du cinéma comme ça pour mieux
faire passer le message aujourd'hui qui
puisait sur l'environnement Robert
Rochefort
écouter ça m'amuse un peu je veux dire
je sais pas le premier je veux dire les
Américains ont commencé avant les
Européens à utiliser comme ça des
vedettes même certaines de ces vedettes
sont devenues des chefs d'État donc du
cinéma mais en même temps
je trouve que c'est une misère de la
politique que de que de faire ça bon
François Hollande est dans une grande
opération de communication j'espère que
le sommet de fin d'année à Paris
aboutira effectivement à quelque chose
d'ambitieux je n'en suis pas
complètement convaincu pour être honnête
et d'ailleurs les les échos que j'ai de
de collègues qui sont dans des groupes
de travail préparatoires me disent que
c'est évidemment extrêmement difficile
et les les grands sommets précédents
vous savez je suis toujours un peu un
peu prudent c'est à dire que plus la
déclaration est belle plus ensuite qu'il
s'agisse de lutte contre la grande
pauvreté qui s'agisse des questions
d'environnement plus il arrive que les
résultats derrière soient extrêmement
décevants bon là on est on est on est
dans un show bon mais en même temps vous
me permettrez de considérer que c'est
pas le principal des reproches que je
vais faire à François Hollande depuis
qu'il est président de la République
mais mais là il y a bon il y a quelque
chose qui est voilà qui est un peu je
trouve une une misère de de la politique
je n'ai jamais été en tant que tel
gaulliste mais vous imaginez le général
de Gaulle se faire accompagner par
comment dire une grande comédienne
française même si on dit qu'il n'était
pas complètement insensible aux charmes
de certaines de ces grandes comédiennes
mais enfin c'est un autre c'est un autre
temps bien entendu vous avez raison de
le dire mais ce que nous voulons
aujourd'hui c'est quand même plutôt
restaurer les valeurs de la politique
restaurer le débat démocratique
restaurer comment dire des choses de
cette nature mais encore une fois je je
n'en veux pas fondamentalement de faire
ce voyage un petit peu people comme
comme on pourrait dire je suis
d'ailleurs assez étonné qui est pas eu
des clins d'oeil avec ses propres
questions people à lui mais c'est pas à
moi d'en parler mais Adrien Gomez vous
pensez que François Hollande il peut
incarner celui qui va influer pour
aboutir à un accord
je voudrais revenir deux petites
secondes sur ce que vient des Robert
rochoirs je suis en accord avec lui sur
le la critique de la pipolisation de la
politique pour autant là pour moi
l'objectif est un peu un peu différent
dans le sens où l'idée c'est quand même
de d'inviter les grands groupes et les
entreprises a signé un certain nombre
d'accord commerciaux et à investir
davantage dans le dans le développement
dans le domaine du développement durable
donc faire venir deux actrices qui ont
une notoriété internationale etc c'est
pas forcément une mauvaise chose y
compris pour le développement durable
et qui sont engagés en ce sens il y a
pas de manipulation exactement voilà
tout à fait mais il vous permettez juste
pour je vous rends la parole une seconde
vie je préférerais comment dire une
délégation commune de chef d'État
européen et je vous garantis que ça
aurait de la gueule quand Madame Merkel
et Monsieur Hollande vont voir Monsieur
Poutine pour la question de l'Ukraine ça
a quand même de la gueule mais écoutez
je préférerais moi qu'il y ait le
président Juncker plus de la Commission
européenne + 3 ou 4 chefs d'État je
trouve que ça ce serait quelque chose
qui aux yeux du monde
resterait comment dire la politique et
serait un engagement commun pour
l'avenir de la planète plutôt qu'un chef
d'État unique d'un pays certes
importants en Europe qui accueillera le
voilà la Réunion mais et alors parce que
effectivement la France oui mais
d'accord mais est-ce qu'on aille cette
conférence au nom d'une France toute
seule qui pense qu'à elle toute seule
accompagnée de deux vedettes on arrive à
changer de cours des choses ou est-ce
que c'est une France qui est capable de
comprendre que elle n'est visible
aujourd'hui aux yeux d'un monde nouveau
qui justement pas le même que tu dis à
40 ans que quand elle est au sein d'un
ensemble plus large qui s'appelle
l'Europe Adrien Gomy c'est vrai mais
vous évoquez tout à l'heure la tradition
Gauliste et vous devriez vous vous
réjouir que la France soit à
l'initiative
non il est certain que là il y a quand
même quelque chose d'important et
François Hollande a un rôle primordial à
jouer dans la préparation de la
conférence de Paris sur le climat qui
aura lieu à la fin de l'année 2015 avec
ce fameux qui avait été créé je crois à
la conférence de Copenhague en 2009 et
qui a pour objectif d'un tas de 100
milliards de dollars par an donc il va
falloir
justement
oui tout à fait et justement pourquoi
pas voir attendre de voir ce que fait
François Hollande il a l'initiative sur
cette question là une question qui est
particulièrement importante en 2015 on
verra bien ce qui ce qui en ressort et
vous pensez qu'il a le point je reviens
à ma question pour vous faire bouger les
lignes et qu'on aboutisse à un accord en
décembre entre les pays il n'aura pas le
poids tout seul c'est c'est évident de
faire rien aujourd'hui comme le disait
Robert Rochefort de façon isolée dans le
dans le monde
qui est le nôtre pour autant il peut
être à l'initiative oui il peut porter
un certain message entouré de ces deux
actrices il peut porter un certain
message assez assez intéressant à
destination de l'ensemble du monde oui
collectif le cercle des nouveaux
réformistes vous étiez notre
éditorialiste dans le 12-14 info avec
Robert Rochefort député européen et
vice-président du MoDem merci beaucoup
messieurs pour votre participation et
j'espère à très bientôt